hey guys it's Justine and today we are
unboxing all of the iPhone 14s we have
the new iPhone 14 pro Max in the purple
the iPhone 14 pro in the space black and
the iPhone 14 in this beautiful blue
color we don't have the plus because
that does come out later but right now
we're gonna unbox all three of these and
check them out
oh
look at you
I did see it at the event but like
seeing it here in person in my very own
Studio
so exciting look at it this blue is
honestly I think one of my favorite
colors it's just like the perfect baby
blue color
it's beautiful this does have that all
glass back and I like the Frosted camera
bump right there it does look really
nice and I really like the aluminum
sides here do not get fingerprints
because in the pros it has the shiny
stainless steel finish and you get so
many fingerprints on it with this even
though it is aluminum no fingerprints
one down two to go oh look at this USBC
cable here's the iPhone 14 pro look at
that box beautiful shiny shimmering
splendid
no oh the black looks so nice I really
was struggling on which one to order for
my personal phone I did order the silver
and I know I probably should have got
the purple because it is the new color
but I had gold the last two phones and I
decided to go with the silver just
because I like having the light camera
showing whenever I have a case on it
ready for the peel
there was like no sound there was no
ASMR peel sound
okay this black looks so good on camera
just moving this around on the light oh
wow
this makes me even more excited to open
up the purple speaking of which let's do
it this is our all new deep purple color
let's check it out
oh
no did I make a mistake should I have
ordered the purple Jake you ordered the
purple didn't you
um it's really pretty it's so pretty oh
my goodness wow my sister also ordered
the purple what was I thinking look at
that oh my God it's nice it's so nice my
precious
I've never seen the movie I don't get
the reference but this just looks so
pretty okay ready time for the peel it's
like Whispering I don't know why I'm
whispering there's nobody else here
[Music]
you look great so we now have all three
of our devices all unboxed look at them
look at this beautiful lineup my
children I'm so proud so now we have our
phones let's check out the accessories
so here's the iPhone 14 pro Max leather
case this is in the purple
oh wait is this purple Pro Max leather
case oh it's this is an ink this looks
nice it's not really a purple color but
it's more of like a kind of a Navy but
it does have a purple kind of tint to it
there's the case and the phone
as much as I don't like putting cases on
my phone I have to because I cannot be
trusted now we're gonna open up the
leather wallet that comes in the ink
color as well
I did some weird stuff with my pre-order
I pre-ordered a pink chalk case with the
orange wallet with what was I even
thinking is that a combo that's gonna
look good I'm not sure but that's what I
ordered
so since I would say about last year I
have pretty much been only a magsafe
wallet person I never thought that this
was something that I would ever be able
to do and I've made it an entire year
only with this wallet on the back of my
phone it's also made me keep way less
carbs than I did before I basically only
have one credit card I have my driver's
license and my Tesla key card and if
anybody remembers my video from last
year I went and bought my Tesla instead
of filming my iPhone 13 video I'm so
nervous I've wanted one for a really
long time okay I went through
oh my gosh
[Music]
the iPhone 14 pro is all suited up let's
close our iPhone 14 pro this is the
iPhone 14 silicon case this is in the
midnight color I'm confused as to what
the midnight color is because it's not
blue but it's also not black like it's
dark navy blue color oh that looks
that looks pretty black to me like this
midnight has more of a blue this it's
way
more black
interesting okay let's put on your
outfit
that looks really nice too voila
and we've got our iPhone 14 silicone
case this is in storm blue
oh that's a much darker blue than I
thought my mom would love this color she
loves the color blue I think I'm gonna
have to get her this color iPhone case
okay let's put your clothes on look at
you looking so pretty this is a perfect
combo I like that this has like the dark
blue around the edge it kind of
complements the light blue matches the
logo like this looks good this is a
beautiful combination so here's the
previous blue color case that I have
right now on my phone almost like the
same color
I feel like as the iPhone 14
very similar colors yeah so here's the
12 Pro Max Blue that matches
pretty close to this new case
look at our friends
the whole gang is here
I told Tim Cook that I was ordering the
purple phones you lied to Tim Cook's
face I did but honestly at the time I
thought that I was gonna get the purple
so which one are you gonna get the Deep
Purple the Deep Purple for sure yeah
I lied to Tim Cook
so here's all three of the phones the
pro model as you can see has the always
on display so this is actually not on I
mean it's on but it's not now it's on
this is our iPhone 14 which does not
have the always on display look at that
it's cool all right we're all unboxed
and now it's time to go out and test
them out
foreign
14s we've got the iPhone 14 the 14 pro
and the 14 pro Max with a new brighter
display on the pros with a Max knit
brightness of 2000 increased performance
camera enhancements crash detection and
new emergency satellite connectivity
let's say hello to this year's iPhones
the iPhone 14 has a 6.1 inch xdr Max
1200 nits display durable ceramic Shield
12 megapixel front-facing camera with 49
improved low light along with the new 14
they have an iPhone 14 plus option with
a larger display these do have the same
a15 bionic chip as the iPhone 13 pros
from last year but with thermal
optimizations to basically make this a
13 Pro and a new 14 body upgrade for
Less now the iPhone 14 Pros have an
additional telephoto lens that the
iPhone 14 does not have the display is
1600 nits with a Max brightness of 2000
and now the display has the ability to
be always on but the new a16 bionic chip
we can shoot 48 megapixel Raw photos and
all new action mode to stabilize your
video and improved camera system with up
to 3x improved low light on the ultra
camera a new 2x telephoto option and the
most exciting new feature turning that
cut out into something actually quite
useful for notifications and controlling
your content now only the iPhone 14 Pro
Models will have the dynamic Island the
iPhone 14 Dean still has the notch
[Music]
so we're now outside I've got both of
the phones I have the iPhone 14 pro Max
and the iPhone 14 I'm going to go around
take some photos take some videos we're
definitely going to be testing out that
action mode and spoiler I've already
tested it out and I am so impressed I
can't even explain can't wait to show
you guys
cinematic mode got an upgrade this year
on the 14s you can now shoot in 4k 24
frames a second and 30 frames a second
now before you could only shoot in 1080
and you couldn't actually change the
frame rate to 24 frames a second so I'm
very excited the now cinematic mode has
actually become a little more cinematic
now on the 14 you only have one lens
option but on the 14 pro Max you can
shoot in 1X and 3X so let's see what
they look like
foreign
about cinematic mode is in post you're
able to select the things that you want
to be in Focus so right now I'm choosing
the tree to be selected that's in focus
and then if I want myself to be in Focus
I just tap and guess what now I'm in
focus and this is really cool because
we're basically able to do this on a
phone normally you would need all types
of high-end lenses and all kinds of gear
to make this work and it's just like
magic
[Music]
now here's a test of the 3x zoom on
cinematic and like I said on the iPhone
14 pro Max you're able to get a 3X Zoom
so this is what it looks like in 3x now
let's go to 1x and in that same position
here is what it looks like in the 1X
this is kind of cool because it'll give
you a variety of ways to shoot in
cinematic mode
[Music]
so macro mode is now a little bit more
crisp than the previous iPhone 12 so I'm
so excited to test this out because even
last year when I first got macro mode it
was so shocking because it's so crisp
and you can get so close to things so
like look how close I am to this Cactus
like I'm I'm touching it I also think I
might have got stabbed
[Applause]
[Music]
so our macro mode is supposed to give us
some crisper photos so let's take a
couple and we can compare it to the
iPhone 13. I'm so close to this tree
like I'm My Lens I feel like is touching
it
[Music]
and this right here is the macro mode so
if I decide that I don't want to shoot
in macro I can turn that off and I'll be
able to
shoot a regular photo but if I want that
back on
press it and we are in business like the
thing is the iPhone 13 is still an
incredible phone like these photos still
was really great
[Music]
so we're back here in the studio and I
want to give you guys a closer look at
the dynamic Island and this has been
actually super impressive but now that
I've been going back and using my iPhone
13. it's been so weird without it
because I actually really miss it even
though apple is using this as a way to
kind of have a little distraction away
from the pill shaped design that is kind
of there because it has to be there for
the camera and for the face ID and the
infrared it's actually really really
helpful so for an example I will open up
some Spotify here let's of course listen
to a little
um Bebe rexha this new track is fire so
it automatically goes up there and the
top right here and when you press into
it
the notification kind of Pops down and
you can have access to to pause to play
make it go away now if we start a timer
for instance this will also go up to the
top and you'll see it's right here
we can have access to the timer I can
stop that over it I also have really
liked this for screen recording because
I do a lot of screen recordings all the
time when I'm making videos so having
this little screen recorder pop up at
the top is super helpful another thing
that I really like it for is face ID and
it'll automatically give all of my info
and I can log in
[Music]
foreign
action mode and the reason that I have
these set up like this is because I
wanted to test the iPhone 14 Pros up
against each other so one is going to be
recording in action mode and the other
is not going to be recording in action
mode and we're going to show you guys
the difference so in action mode it's
actually punching in slightly so there
is a little bit of a crop and because of
that you will notice that if you are
shooting in Ultra wide that there is a
little bit more of a crop than when
you're shooting it Ultra wide when
you're not using action mode here we go
all right action mode
okay so these are both in point five now
let's switch to one so my action mode
camera is staying at 0.5 and I've
switched the other one to one so you can
kind of see the similar crop
I'm getting so much activity with these
reviews
okay Jake you ready to follow me let's
go
watching both of these back is so
shocking I mean even the one that's not
in action mode is still pretty steady
but when you compare that to action mode
like I was running really fast also
something that was kind of cool is even
at the beginning where I asked Jake a
question and he moved the phones
the action mode one didn't even move at
all now most of the time you're not
going to be running around full speed
chasing people so what is a more real
world scenario when you would use action
mode maybe just walking around vlogging
filming so now one of these recording in
action mode which is this one right here
and the other is recording in 1X which
would be the equivalent because of the
crop now this is more of a normal I feel
like everyday scenario walking around
talking vlogging and then if I were to
take the camera off of you Jake this is
what it would look like
there's my friends back there
we are what if I jump
what if I spin around in circles
I don't know
the new iPhone 14 has a 1600 nit display
with Peak brightness up to 2 000. this
is so exciting because I'm always using
my phone outside and on bright sunny
days especially here in Los Angeles it's
pretty bright and you can still see your
display
now one of the things that you need to
set up when you get your iPhone is make
sure that the formats are correct you
have to go into the camera settings turn
on Apple Pro raw and you want to make
sure that the resolution is set to 48
megapixels to really take advantage of
that full format and another thing that
I recommend this is my favorite is the
macro control so you want to make sure
that that is on as well because that
will let you adjust the macro if it's on
or off and sometimes you might not
actually want to use it when you're
taking a photo so it's always best to
turn that on
crash detection is something new in the
iPhone 14 and in the Apple watches so if
you do happen to unfortunately get into
a car accident the Apple watch and the
iPhone will both be able to alert
emergency authorities that there has
been an accident and they can be
directed directly to the scene what I
think is such an amazing safety
precaution and I'm so excited that that
is something that they decided to put in
all of the new devices this year
foreign
[Music]
launching in November you'll have access
to satellite Communications so I'm
personally very excited about this
because I do have a satellite phone that
I like to take with me hiking now the
one downside to the iPhone satellite
communication is it really is only for
emergencies whereas the satellite that I
pay for monthly which is like 60 a month
through Garmin you can actually connect
to the satellites send text messages and
communicate so yes it is for emergencies
but you can still send text messages
whereas only the satellite on the iPhone
is for emergency response so you really
can't go and text message your friends
using satellite it's only to contact the
authorities and let them know that you
have a problem it's kind of cool how
they made this work is they actually
will turn your phone into the satellite
finder so as you're moving around the
iPhone will direct you to where the
satellite is it'll then connect you to
the emergency responders they've done
something very interesting though with
the text messages they're able to
condense the size of that text message
to ensure it gets delivered a lot of
times when you communicate painting with
satellites it can take 5 10 15 20
minutes to just send a single message up
and back down to the recipient so
they've made it that the file size is as
small as possible to make sure that your
message gets delivered so that means if
I wash up on a beach just like this and
I didn't have my phone or any reception
guess what I can call for help
on my satellite device
my iPhone 14. love it
[Music]
[Applause]
so we're shooting this right now and
prores I thought I would test it out
it's kind of amazing that I'm able to
shoot prores 4K Raw on an iPhone it's
pretty impressive
[Music]
we're at the beach now the sun is about
to set and I'm testing out the
front-facing camera because one of the
things that they did update is the
front-facing camera which like I'm kind
of excited about but also not excited
because the front facing is where I like
to take those nice selfies we don't need
to see all of the lines we don't need to
see all the details Apple you're making
things too good now oh hashtag no filter
foreign
[Music]
something I've been so excited to test
out is the low light photography it has
been improved in the new iPhone 14 so
we're going to do a little comparison
between the 14 and the 13. now it might
look like on camera here there's a lot
of light I mean I guess we can turn off
those overhead lights and see what they
look like so lights on
oh wow
that's way darker it looks like daylight
when I hold this up it also takes faster
night mode photos because of the a16
bionic chip so you don't have to hold
your phone as still for so long so let's
take a couple and test it out we've got
the new iPhone over here
and I'm gonna go ahead and take a
picture one two
so it definitely looks just First
Impressions sharper and then three two
one
[Music]
foreign
thank you
wow okay so it already looks way
cleaner
this one yeah yeah this is new okay good
the one on the right looks way better
it is blurry too
I've been having so much fun testing out
these films and one of my favorite
features which is kind of surprising is
having the always-on display it's kind
of shocking every time I look down at my
phone when it's just sitting at the
table and it's on it's on but it's not
on I also enjoyed testing out all of the
new features like the Cinematic mode and
the action mode was definitely one of
the things that was really shocking it
worked so well I can't wait to use that
more I'll have a bunch more videos
coming up very soon so if you haven't
already please subscribe hit the Bell to
be notified when I post new videos and I
have some other videos here that you may
be interested in Apple related of course
and with that I will see you guys in the
next video bye